Speaker 1: Why don't we go next over to let's
go to Jiron from Atlanta. Jiron, you're on
the air.
Speaker 5: Hey, David, thank you so much for
having me on.
Speaker 1: My pleasure.
Speaker 5: I wanted to ask about what you
thought of the job that Janet Yellen has been
doing, especially with this New Deal, the
world corporate global tax minimum. I want
to know what you thought about that.
Speaker 1: Yeah, I mean, my general take on
Yellen so far is she's she's been predictable.
We had a sense, you know, when she was selected
by Joe Biden, there were some on the left
who said this is another neo liberal centrist.
And, you know, I took the time of digging
into papers. She's written and work that she's
done. And she's definitely, you know, she
she she's definitely not a socialist. Right.
Which is no surprise. Neither is Joe Biden,
but her perspectives are sort of as left as
one might imagine a mainline Democratic president
would have when it comes to her outlook on
inflation and interest rates. It's been sort
of unremarkable, but I'm basically with her
about it's really too soon to make any serious
decisions or have any serious sense of the
direction that inflation is going. As far
as the global wealth tax, I saw the proposal
some period of time. Did something new happen
in the last week that I missed with it?
Speaker 5: I haven't seen anything about that,
I just saw the G7 deal,
Speaker 1: I think it's an interesting idea.
And for people who don't know, the point of
of some of this is if you can get countries
to come together and say all of us are going
to agree that individuals cannot avoid taxes
in one member country by shifting income to
another member country. And we want a base
minimum level of global tax that is going
to be paid. I think it's an interesting idea.
I see it very difficult to enforce. And it's
one of those things where I would really want
to know the details of how they're proposing
it be done. And then where would disputes
be adjudicated related to it, like there's
questions which maybe have been answered and
I haven't looked into it enough yet. I think
it's super interesting. I don't know how you
really get it done.
Speaker 5: Yeah, I think it's great that she's
starting to hold as well as the other economic
leaders of the free world, starting to hold
multinational corporations accountable.
Speaker 1: Yeah, absolutely, absolutely. With
that being the end goal is something I'm completely
behind the implementation. And how you get
it done is where I where I want to know more.
Speaker 5: And also, just one quick thing
for the future outlook of Yellen. Do you think
she'll be able to do a good job of managing
inflation as we get out of this pandemic phase?
Speaker 1: You know, I do think so, I mean,
I I think she seems to understand that the
numbers from March and April really don't
tell us what we need to know to come up with
a comprehensive and more reliable outlook.
I have every confidence that she has the knowledge
and experience to successfully manage inflation.
I have no real concern right now.
Speaker 5: Well, thank you, that's really
great insight, I'm I'm just a high schooler,
I took an economics class, NOAA political
class stuff really interests me. So I really
appreciate you taking the time.
Speaker 1: Brilliant. All right. Thank you
for the call, Jaron. Thank you so much. All
right. Wow. Jiron in high school would not
have guessed that from the from the questions
that were coming in